الجويه تركيه هل حصلت على ضوء اخضر روسي
امريكي على الاقل طرف روسي وامريكي تعرفين
رشيده ان خطه تركيا التي اعلنت عنها في
ايار الماضي لتنفيذ هجوم بري
وتثبيت ماذا تعتبره منطقه امنه بعمق 30
كلم في الاراضي السوريه انا ذاك كان هناك
معارضه قويه امريكيه وروسيا وايرانيه
اليوم على همم بعد تفجير تقسيم في اسطنبول
واتهام انقره مباشره قوات كرديه بالوقوف
ورائي وانا المنفذه امراه سوريه همم كرديه
رغم نفي وهمم القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
هذا الاتهام بكل الاحوال جاء اعلنت
مسؤوليتها عن هذا التفجير تركيا تستفيد من
همم بطبيعه الحال من هذه المناسبه للقول
للامريكيين للروس من الانترنت على الهجوم
داخل اراضيها التركيه من هنا
طرف امريكي تبين مثلا من خلال بيان امريكي
صدر عن قنصليه الامريكيه في اربيل يقول
بانهك تقارير عن عمليه
وشيكا وعلى الامريكي توقي الحدث الجانب
الروسي ايضا لم يعارض علنا الذي هو يسيطر
على الاجواء السوريه عمليا لم يعارض مثلا
هذا القصف بشكل واضح او همم معلن قوي كما
في مره سابقه وايران ايضا مشغوله بازمه
الداخليه الاكراد المعارضين لها الذين
تقصفهم ايضا في همم
كردستان تركيا تريد من هذه الضربات الجويه
الان بطبيعه الحال هي عقابيه بحق المعاقل
التي تعتقد او تقول بان هي التي تهاجم
تركيا وفي الوقت نفسه همم في اجواء داخليه
تركيه بحاجه الحكومه التركيه والتحالف
العداله والتنميه
ااا الحفاظ على الهيبه قبل انتخابات حاسمه
واساسيه في الحزيران المقبله انتخابات
رئاسيه في هذه النقاش الانتخابي المساله
السوريه حاضره بقوه من خلال اللعبه الذي
يمثله اللاجئون في الداخل
والصعود مشاعر معاديه للاجئين المهاجرين
ومساعي تركيا للقول بانهم ينتقلون الى
مناطق داخل سوريا من هذا الملف هذا صعب
جدا بالنسبه للحكومه التركيه وتستفيد الان
من هذه الظرف
للحفاظ على نوع من الهيبه بهذا الشان من
هنا همم هذه الضربات لا تعارضها الكوره في
الوقت نفسه السؤال هو هل يمكن لانقره
تحقيق اهداف ميدانيه في الميدان من خلال
قصف من الجو بمعنى الحفاظ على السيطره على
مدن او توسيع الشريط الذي تريده هنا
السؤال الذي
اليوم مع التلويح بعمليه بريه وفي هذا
السياق وسيم رئيسه تركيه رجب طيب اردوغان
اشاره اليوم الى منق الى مناقشات بشان
مشاركه قوات بريه هل هذا الهجوم البري
وارد يعني همم وارد لكنه هناك محاذير كبرى
يعني حتى الرئيس اردوغان يعني الذي صرح
خلال العودته من قطر مشاركه في المونديال
همم قال انه
سيكون هناك مناقشات لاستخدام ول- لاشراك
القوات البريه في الهجوم انه لن يقتصر على
ضربات الجويه لم يتحدث كما في المرات
السابقه بشكل واضح عن عمليه محدده الاهداف
لتثبيت شريط بعمق 30 كلم وعندما يقول هذا
الامر نعرف ان تركيا خاضت عمليات سابقا في
الاراضي السوريه نرى الخريطه الان بقي
هناك مناطق اساسيه مدن الخاصه كوباني وتل
رفعت ومنبج ومنطقه في ضمن بنك اهداف تركيا
تريد استكمال ما تعتبره شريطه حدوديا امنا
ميعاد المقاتلين الاكراد عن حدودها بعمق
30 كم الا انه يمكن يعني في اي عمليه بريه
لها محاذير يعني ممكن مثلا دخول الى
كوباني او رفعت لكن هل يمكن البقاء من دون
خسائر هل يمكن البقاء من دون مقاومه في
اجواء انتخابيه داخل تركيا هذا الامر فيه
محاذير كبرى اذا كان هناك خسائر تركيه
النقطه الثانيه ان صحيح الولايات المتحده
التي تدعم الاكراد والتركيه همم تقول
اليوم بان يجب ان توقف دعمهم بالسلاح
وغيره غض الطرف عن ضربات جويه لكن هل
ستقبل مثلا عمليه بريه من هذا النوع اذا
كانت كله يعتمد على حدود هذه العمليه
والنطاق الذي تقول انقر ان تذهب اليه وحتى
روسيا هل ستراهن انقر بعمليه من هذا النوع
بالتفاهمات خاصه التفاهمات الثانويه وضعت
خطوط التماس يوم تتهم روسيا بعدم تنفيذ
التزاماتها بابعاد المقاتلين وقطر
المقاتلين الاكرار بمعنى هناك احاديث كبرى
على
ااه في الميدان ولها انعكاسات على الداخل
التركي يجعل ان هذه العمليه البريه قد تتم
لكن
ليس مؤكدا انها ستكون في نفس النطاق
لتحدثت عنه سابقا انقره يبقى التساؤل ااه
رشيده انه هل تلويح بهذه العمليه هذه
العمليه وفي اجواء الرد على تفجير اسطنبول
هو ايضا نوع من الاستفاده من هذا الظرف
اليوم وانشغال روسيا في اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده ايضا في اوكرانيا وفي
انتخاباتها وايران مشغوله كل طرف مشغول في
له حسابات خاصه به لرفع سقف المطالب
التركيه وضعها على طاوله استانه بمعنى ان
هناك همم الجوله جديده
لاستانا التي تضم ايران وتركيا وروسيا
بشان سوريا في همم اعتبارا من الغد هل
تركيا تريد ايضا من خلال تلويح بعمليه
بريه وضع هذه المطالب على الطاوله لحصول
على مكتسبات ضمانات ابعاد المقاتلين مناطق
معينه اخرجهم مناطق يعني بمعنى التحقيق
اهداف او على الاقل جزء من اهداف العمليه
البريه من دون خوضها وافضل الحروب عاده
ثانيه لتعقق اهدافها بدون البدء او الخوض
بها بانتظار الايام والساعات المقبله لكن
واضحه اننا في مرحله تصعيد على اشده شكرا
لك يا زميلي وسيم على كل هذه التفاصيل